ايام مرعبه كتم فيها العالم انفاسه كان
اقرب من اي وقت مضى لحرب نوويه مدمره تكتب
نهايه البشريه قطب العالم النوويان يعدان
العده ويحصيان عدد الضحايا المحتمليه انها
ازمه الصواريخ الكوبيه عندما اوشك العالم
على الزوال بحرب نوويه بين الولايات
المتحده هو الاتحاد السوفيتي
عام 59 وصل فيديل كاسترو على راس السلطه
في كوبا معلنا عدا تاريخيا للجار الامريكي
الولايات المتحده وقتها وصفت كوبا بدوله
شيوعيه في حديقتها الخلفيه على الفور
انتبه الرسل هذا الخلاف فسارعوا لمد حبال
الود والدعم لكوبا التي تعتبر النقطه
الاقرب جغرافيا للولايات المتحده
السوفيات كانوا يريدون رد الصفعه لامريكا
التي نشرت منصه صواريخ باليستيه في تركيا
تستطيع ضرب اراضيهم بهجمات نوويه فاستغلوا
الخلاف بين كاسترو والرئيس الامريكي حينها
وبداوا بخطتهم الجريئه
نشر صواريخ باليستيه في كوبا التي لا تبعد
عن ولايه فلوريدا الامريكيه سوى 90
كيلومترا فقط
60 سفينه تجاريه نقلت الصواريخ بشكل سري
ترافقها بعض الغواصات الروسيه اوصلت 24
منصه اطلاق صواريخ واكثر من اربعين صاروخا
وخمسه واربعين راسا نوويا الى البر الكوبي
اضافه الى ما يقارب الف عسكري
هنا البيت الابيض الاستخبارات الامريكيه
تعلم الرئيس كينيدي باكتشاف امر الصواريخ
السوفيتيه على الفور تم نشر صواريخ ارض جو
حول العاصمه واشنطن وخرج كينيدي ليعلن
عزلان على كوبا واستهداف اي سفينه تتجه
الى سواحلها
لقد حافظت هذه الحكومه كما وعدت على
مراقبه اوثق التعزيزات العسكريه السوفيتيه
في جزيره كوبا خلال الاسبوع الماضي اثبتت
ادله لا لبس فيها حقيقه ان سلسله من مواقع
الصواريخ الهجوميه قيد الاعداد الان في
تلك الجزيره لا يمكن ان يكون الغرض من هذه
القواعد سوى توفير قدره الضربه النوويه ضد
نصف الكره الغربي
كندي طالب موسكو بسحب كل الصواريخ من كوبا
لكن الرئيس السوفيتي
رفض التهديد مطالبا واشنطن بسحب صواريخها
هي ايضا من تركيا
ومؤكدا ان سفنه ستكمل طريقها الى كوبا هنا
وصلت توتر الى اعلى مستوياته القوات
الجويه الامريكيه رفعت درجه استعدادها
القتالي الى مستوى دفكون اثنين وهي حاله
تاهب قصوات تسبق وقوع الحرب وفي كواليس
البيت الابيض يقدر المسؤولون اعداد
الضحايا للرد السوفيتي ثلث سكان امريكا
سيختفون من الضربه النوويه الاولى لسوفيات
كيف يمكننا ان نعيش ونعمل مع الاتحاد
السوفيتي كيف يمكننا منع اندلاع الحرب كيف
يمكننا حمايه امنه كيف يمكننا الحفاظ على
السلام الان ستختبر هذه المشاكل افضل ما
لدينا جميعا
العالم حبس انفاسه البشريه على بعد خطوه
واحده من حرب عالميه ثالثه
لكنها نوويه هذه المره فكر كينيدي
بالاطاحه بكسترو ومن ثم فرض الوصايه على
كوبا فارسل بعض المتمردين الكوبيين في
عمليه عرفت اعلاميا بخارج الخنازير لكنها
فشلت فشلا ذريعا
لن ياتي احد للتفقد احوال بلادنا لا تحت
هذا العلم ولا اي علم اخر نحن نعرف ما
نقوم به ونعرف كيف ندافع عن سلامتنا
وسياده اراضينا النصر سيكون ملكا للجميع
هنا الوطن او الموت سوف ننتصر
ثلاثه عشر يوما من التهديدات بين الاتحاد
السوفيتي والولايات المتحده خلالها ادرك
كاسترو حجم المخاطره بوجود السفيه على
ارضه التي ستكون اول ما يدمر في حرب نوويه
وشيكا لكنه اصر على موقفه بعدم تدخل
امريكا في شؤون بلاده على الجانب الاخر لم
تكن موسكو اقل تحفظا فالكارثه ستطال
الجميع بادر الروس برساله الى كندي تعد
بازاله الصواريخ مقابل وقف الحصار وعدم
غزو كوبا اضافه الى نزع الصواريخ
الامريكيه من تركيا الامر الذي وافقت عليه
واشنطن
ليتنفس العالم الصعداء بنهايه واحده من
اخطر الازمات في تاريخ البشريه